انضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراس الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس اجمل لنا ابرز المستجدات
وماذا عن شارع عشره وفقا
لرؤيتكم فدا القصف مستمر حقيقه على
المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه وواضح بانه
يستهدف هذه هذا الشارع على وجه الخصوص على
اعتبار كما يبدو ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يريد
ان يواصل فصل
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه عن وسطها
وجنوبها ذلك ان هذا الشارع الرئيس والمهم
هو شارع يمتد من المناطق الشرقيه لقطاع
غزه ويصل حتى البحر هو شارع عرضي وكان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد سيطر عليه منذ اليوم
الاول للعمليه البريه على اعتبار ان هذا
المحور محور مهم في عمليه الفصل ما بين
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه وما بين وسطها
وجنوبها و كما يبدو ان القصف المدفعي الذي
يستهدف هذه المنطقه تحديدا هدفه منع عوده
الفلسطينيين الى مناطق الشمال الى ديارهم
الى منازلهم في المنطقه الشماليه وهذا
الموضوع سئل عنه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ليله امس في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
عقده بمرور 100 يوم على الحرب وقال بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي لن يسمح للفلسطينيين
بالعوده الى المناطق الشماليه للقطاع
للقطاع ما زال او ما دام القتال مستمرا
وقال بان القتال ما زال مستمرا بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه فدا تحدثت عن هذه
النقطه تحديدا في الايام الماضيه ونقلت عن
مصادر امنيه واستخبارات قولها بان اسرائيل
تتمسك في هذه المساله كورقه مساومه في اي
اتفاق او اي صفقه لتبادل الاسرى اي
مستقبلا بمعنى ان عوده الفلسطينيين الى
منازلهم في المنطقه الشماليه سيكون مرهونا
او جزءا ربما من المفاوضات على صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى لذلك يبدو ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي من خلال قصفه لهذه المنطقه
ربما هنالك عمليات عسكريه ايضا تدور رحاها
في هذه المنطقه المستهدفه بالمدفعيه وبغار
الجويه لكن واضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي كما
يبدو يحاول ان يق قع الطريق على اي
محاولات ربما ايضا من جانب الفلسطينيين
للانتقال من المناطق الوسطى او الجنوبيه
والعوده الى منازلهم في المناطق الشماليه
جنوب مدينه غزه يتعرض منذ ايام الى قصف
مدفعي شديد القصف المدفعي حقيقه يتركز في
تلك المناطق وهنالك غارات جويه سواء كان
ذلك بالمقاتلات الحربيه بعض الغارات تمت
في الايام الماضيه حتى من علو منخفض جدا
هنا في هذه ال منطقه وكذلك من خلال
المروحيات العسكريه من نوع اباتشي التي
تكاد لا تغادر اجواء المنطقه هذه منطقه
غلاف غزه واحيانا توجه زخات من الرشاشات
الثقيله باتجاه مواقع مختلفه ايذا القصف
المدفعي كما تسمعين فدى متواصل كما قلت
يستهدف المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه لكن
ايضا ال المخيمات في وسط قطاع غزه تحديدا
البريج ونصرا والمغر وغيرها من المناطق
هذه المناطق ما زالت حتى الان تتعرض لقصف
مدفعي شديد ونحن نسمع ايضا بين الحين
والاخر اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله
وهذا يعني بان القتال على الارض القتال في
الميدان ما زال على اشده وان المقاومه ما
زالت تملك القدره كما يبدو على مواجهه
القوات الاسرائيليه التي اجتاحت هذه
المناطق في الاسابيع الماضيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان زخم عملياته العسكريه
يتركز حاليا في منطقه الجنوب تحديدا في
منطقه خانيونس وان العمليات العسكريه هناك
في اوجهها وهي مستمره وان كانت تسير ببطء
شديد وبحذر شديد لان التقديرات
الاستخباراتيه والامنيه الاسرائيليه تشير
الى ان المحتجزين الاسرائيليين موجودون في
تلك المنطقه شكرا لك لياس كرام كنت معنا
من غلاف غزه